go through the challenges of life
challenge myself having a challenge I
love challenges challenge so much and
challenging yourself cool challenge
looking for challenges taking on
challenges face to tell it
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that will change the planet and
so to help you on your journey today
we're gonna learn how to challenge
yourself here's what I discovered that
happens to you in life that you will go
through things and while you're going
through them you can't understand why
it's happening to you but after you go
through it you get back and you look at
it and you say oh now I understand why I
needed that lesson have you a little
happened to you is that if you ever
happen to you
but that I did I couldn't understand it
there but after I got through it then I
saw that that was preparing me for
bigger and better things
but as you go through the challenges of
life and you look at it and embrace
whatever comes to you don't run from it
step toward it don't try and duck it
like most people do see most people want
it easy see if you either come easy what
easy go see but when you go out what
you're going to deal with and you deal
with the difficult difficulties of it
when you handle those hard things close
at hand making those hard decisions
right now that you don't want to make
learning those things that you don't
like to do but you know that in order
for you to get where you want to go this
is one of the hoops that you have to
flip through and I'm saying to you
whatever you got to do do it because if
you don't life is gonna whoop you and
tell you surrender and say okay all
right all right all right all right I
cooperate okay I'll learn okay ahead
wear me out a long time so if it's hard
to do it hard
I always did everything back has half
words you know I like to challenge
myself and I went to Mount Lebanon High
School in Pittsburgh and I wanted to
take business classes my junior year
only they didn't offer any business
classes and so I decided I'd take some
college business classes but University
of Pittsburgh didn't offer any real
business classes either so I said you
know I'm gonna challenge myself and so I
took a couple night classes at the
University of Pittsburgh my junior year
in high school did well in them and
didn't wasn't really challenged all that
much at all and so I just dropped out of
high school and instead of going back
for my senior year I went that went to
the University of Pittsburgh and started
taking classes there and like my buddies
were like where'd you go and it just I
just I've always tried to challenge
myself what drives me is having a
challenge and meeting that challenge in
a way that'll hopefully make my peers my
family and my friends proud
part of it is a thrill-seeking as well
although I think you're in a lot of
danger if you just become an adrenaline
junkie but you need stability you need
stamina and you need to be able to keep
your perspective and feel grounded and
secure and what you're doing is not the
thing that I've that I've learned more
this year is that I had a lot of
obviously there were a lot of hopes or
dreams that I had and those things
coming true it it kind of makes you want
to keep dreaming more you know and keep
thinking of the things that will excite
your and I I don't think I knew how much
I loved challenges until Birdman came
along and then and then cabaret because
I was scared I was really I was scared
it's it's um for me it's a very very
different thing and I didn't know that I
was scared to really go there but I was
and Alejandro sort of terrified me and
then breaking through it just it's been
like the most rewarding it was the most
rewarding work I've ever gotten to do
this yeah he's incredible he was the
first player I ever did or acting police
was much ado about nothing which now we
all studied his film over and over again
and down
so they've to come full circle and work
with Nellie's was incredible okay Ken's
one of the people have never been
challenged so much with changing things
yeah I'm doing it different okay we've
got that now try this and and it really
gets you out of that sort of you know
bad habit of saying on my character only
dust this I think that you know when you
limp yourself like that you limit
possibilities and Kim was all about
experimenting and she's going for taking
that risk and work sometimes sometimes
it doesn't and
you know that's part of the journey I
think you always want to be challenging
yourself and pushing yourself in the
work that you do because that's how you
experience those situations you know
it's very easy once you get to a certain
point to be to sort of find your comfort
zone and stay in it and not be
challenged that's not to say that life
won't visit challenges upon you but
you're gonna experience right um but I
think exercising and working out is a
great metaphor for this like I I run
every single day and I like I don't care
what the weather is
I don't care how I'm feeling it's
something I'm gonna subject myself to
and force myself to and you know often
I'll find like I run in the afternoons
for instance and I'll find that I'll be
tired that the day won't have gone very
well you know that maybe I wasn't
feeling great
um but that hour that I'm out there
sweating when I when I come back I'm
ready to go again I've been recharged
and fun I think being able to find that
hey I do better when I'm challenged is a
great thing to teach yourself and and
and and the other thing Tim Ferriss told
me that he was saying you know if you
work out every single day you have a
guaranteed win every single day so your
company might be declaring bankruptcy
but you you set a new PR or you know you
have you you know you got a great rush
of endorphins you'll at least be able to
tell yourself like hey that went well
and that's something that that the
reason I seek out that hardship every
day is that it's a hardship that I'm
sort of guaranteed to overcome I've used
playback in films before and my mind has
a tendency to wander I think it would
have required a different amount of
concentration I also think that it would
have become frustrating to be locked
into a performance one of the things
that was great about the live singing
was that it allowed for multi camera
shooting which is my personal favorite
way to work where you don't have to
worry later on in the day ok what did I
do this morning go back in time what if
you find a new truth in the scene you
can follow it because the take is being
shot in its entirety from all angles so
there's choices in the editing
later on I find that that lets me relax
and let go and the last time that I it
was eight that I shot that way was
Rachel Getting Married
so it was a nice return to to that
format for me and the the one takes
scene that he does for I dreamed a dream
did how many times did you do that and
do you remember in any of those takes
thinking this has got to be the one this
has got to be the one he's going to use
you know I was trying not to think when
I was doing it but but the one that is
in the film when I got to the end of it
I just thought I don't think I can do
better than that I'd like to try but um
but if it's that one I can look I can I
can live with that I can go home and
hang my and keep my head held high
so Tom came out to me after that one was
the fourth take and he said I'm very
happy and I said I I don't want to keep
going and so we shot for another eight
hours and then at the end of that is
eight hours we looked at each other and
said it was that one that we shot in the
morning a beer but it was good to hook
on that full journey so that I know that
that literally even though I I desired
to do better that actually was my best I
found out I guess in March or April of
2011 that there was going to be a film
version of the musical Amos and Hugh
Jackman was probably going to be in it
and I just said oh my gosh I'll play
anybody please just let me audition
which I did a few months later and then
got the part of my that than that
did you know like from before that it
was gonna be like life singing and
because that's a big challenge of it I
think um Thomas still making up his mind
about it you know whether how exactly it
was going to be done how much of it was
going to be live he knew he wanted the
show to be sung through but didn't know
if we would be dropping certain lines
here and there but I thought it was a
great idea I thought it was such a cool
challenge to to try to do that when it's
I don't think I've there been a couple
movies that were sung through the entire
time but not one made recently so I
don't know it seemed like it would be
pretty cool if we were able to pull it
off as actors it as artists you you're
constantly looking for challenges either
in the kind of role that you do or in
the kind of movie
or like even when I did cocktail a
cocktail was completely out of my
comfort zone and I think this was the
right film for me I I remember being
offered you know it's it's public
knowledge I was offered Furious 7 and we
tried so hard to make that work and it
didn't and today when I look back you
know a part of me is like it just wasn't
meant to be
and so I always feel like there's always
a right time for everything and I think
it's this kind of this was just the
right time for it to happen well and it
was the right kind of challenge and in
in a right way I mean of course the you
know the characters exciting but I've
never done this kind of I've done an
action film the formula done this kind
of action before I've been taking on
challenges I've been trying to find out
how good I could be how well I could do
it and in the end I said that the real
benefit of being a successful
entrepreneur is freedom there is nothing
more relevant than freedom being able to
get up every day and respond to what's
out there to accept the challenges to
constantly find out how good you are you
know and with it comes a lot of freedom
life is not flowery not buttery I tell
you as so many challenges life as so
many challenges but the wisdom or
knowledge equips you to face the
challenges the difficulties when you
think life should not have challenges
the challenges will appear even much
bigger to you life
challenges but wisdom equips you to face
them why do you want everything to be
easy take some challenge challenges are
necessary in life what do you think so
everything is so easy so boring see how
people go up on this mountain and jump
from the cliff with the hand glider it's
a challenge some people want to go and
scale Mount Everest someone says oh I
want to sail through the world these
little challenges people take care do
you take some little small challenge it
seems like thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what did you
think what was the clip that resonated
the most with you what was the most
important lesson that you learned and
how are you going to apply it to your
life into your business I love to hear
thoughts if you want to leave a comment
down below I also want to give a quick
shout out to Arman Arman thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and taking that picture
and post into the social that soup looks
really good I kind of want some enjoy
your person the relevant time and I hope
you enjoy the book too so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon